greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by zip recruiter a fresh new year has
begun and if you're setting a new goal
for your business it's extremely
difficult to reach them without the
right people on your team
zip recruiter has transformed how you go
about finding them
zip recruiter post your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards with
just one click
that's why zip recruit is different
unlike other hiring sites zip recruiter
does not depend on the right candidates
finding you it finds them find out today
why zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all sizes and industries
to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now the Church of what's happened
now family can get zip recruiter for
free that's right free just go to zip
recruiter calm slash church that zip
recruiter Tom slash Church one more time
try it for free go to zip recruiter comm
slash Church number two
you know I'm gonna honor it when I'm
down lost in Texas I'm trying to get my
goody bag you know why cuz I can't live
without it I'm a 55 year old dude I got
my head in a thousand places alpha brain
[ __ ] fills the void reefer fills the
void but alpha brain spectacular ok the
shroom tech is finally working
cuz I'm losing weight around my [ __ ]
diaphragm and I'm [ __ ] and doing the
breathing exercises now the shroom tech
is taking it to the next level listen
when it comes to supplements on is the
way to go go down to calm right now
impress in church bam and get 10% off of
your first order delivered right to your
house give it a chance give it a try you
wanted to start a new year
Here I am what an offer you can't [ __ ]
lose ok if you don't like the Alpha
brain tell us we'll send you the money
back we didn't want the product who's
better than [ __ ] alpha brain who's
better than it nobody go to Han that
Preston Church and get the party started
go to zip recruit a Preston church and
get the party started
kick that [ __ ] melee beautiful
[ __ ] then it'll be alive you're
alive and kicking you got the world by
the balls and who's gonna [ __ ] stop
yet nobody didn't have to go to work
please lazy luck
that's one with the king day how are you
mr. Gomez I'm feeling pretty good man
and I cannot imagine to be I cannot
imagine a better way to be celebrating
black culture and Martin Luther King
than getting high with uncle Joey and
lee-sia to my favorite people in the
world definitely my favorite people in
LA this without a doubt this is what I'm
talking about we keep it simple we keep
it real there's no drama there's no
[ __ ] adjectives
there's nobody here sitting here [ __ ]
one of the Hangout and nothing with bare
bones we don't want to do nothing we
just want to [ __ ] talk [ __ ] smoke
reefer and talk to you beautiful people
how was your weekend Lee it was good i
but well first of all about the weekend
I don't know what it says about me well
not the best party I've been to in years
was a five-year-old's birthday party
yeah where she throws a good party she
really does
rock and roll but it is that your kids I
said my son's five-year-old birthday
party yes just last just last Saturday
yes we saw the exact same day we
celebrated our kids fight birth no this
look what did you do it was your son's
birth my son's birthday is December 29
okay but we sit because it was during
the break we wanted him to be back in
school and invitation so we did it yeah
this past Sunday actually sorry so you
did the sixth yeah
oh the seventh around there 7 this is 7
yeah we did her birthday is the 8th but
we did on the 13th it was cool as [ __ ] I
got some Cuban potato balls something I
got some pasta bleep dawg I got all of
them
I got 22 [ __ ] pizzas you did it at
home wasn't coke weed at the park
I got a yard ok but it's limited
I got weights back there I got a
barbecue grill points back there you
know I got a living room set back there
y'all I'd like to sit back there but not
for [ __ ] 60 kids no you know not for
the amount of kids that would come over
barren so there's a park right around
the corner it's clean as [ __ ] his first
come first serve you get the restalls
you put your food out there like a
[ __ ] Puerto Rican beautiful no ever
bothers you oh yeah I mean the conga
drums and he says birthday you're not
allowed to drink that right you can't
jump up and down with booze and rape
wave a Confederate flag well if you
[ __ ] making a few cocktails a
it's a kids party you know I forget that
I gave you parents of course like some
parents I know on the cool side I
brought them all a little pushy like a
like a [ __ ] will what are you eight
yeah I told him cuddly fours don't [ __ ]
around with it yeah I I live in New York
so there's not doing it outside in the
winter see we literally have to rent a
space or do it at one of our apartments
and in New York everything is really
tiny so you can't have [ __ ] 30 kids
running around no we spent like $1500
yeah that's on a five year olds birthday
party that's it yeah unless you gotta go
out listen I could have done it a
thousand places I'm not one of those
dudes she don't need that [ __ ] I don't
want her in that [ __ ] world I'm gonna
tell people to stop with the gifts cuz
they brought that but it was a table
full of [ __ ] gifts took her two days
to open the [ __ ] yes can [ __ ] days
when I left tonight she was putting the
ball with hello well balls into a
[ __ ] bucket so you melt them you have
to get the doll in the ball get a bucket
of water put in there and the thing
fizzles like a blue alka-seltzer
then you stick in and take your toy out
and you don't know what the [ __ ] the toy
is you have to buy it not knowing what
it is it's a mind [ __ ] for the child it
really is a mind four-footed yeah
and she loves it yeah they love it I
don't like it because you don't even
know what you're buying she asked me
whenever you know my Toys R Us get me I
think it's cherry and foxy then my wife
goes you know what find them first of
what Toys R Us number two they're sold
out constantly number two you can't pick
your own dog you gotta keep buying until
you get to the top oh that's how it gets
you know let's think they used to have
at the door yeah like you just open it
up you know see something cool I've
never
that's brilliant so they that's the scam
is they have you you have to keep on
coming back he comes back I love your
[ __ ] daughter so no matter what she
wants you have to say yeah they got
eighty dollars and then any little dolls
that accompany the horse and then
they're gonna [ __ ] come out with a
series to the dolls have the purses do
the TV show yet is that how they get
them no they're on YouTube
Oh even better so there's no they'd have
to wait for new ones they're on YouTube
cuz
[ __ ] around we Blum I'm cutting that
[ __ ] bring it down for explain why you
getting beat yeah you anymore - but I'm
saying you gotta take it home and put in
a thing of water yeah - [ __ ] you figure
out with your buying that's a better
lesson than that yeah it's a much better
gift than that doll like letting her
know she's got to [ __ ] be more savvy
than what the [ __ ] put in water and wait
there like a [ __ ] do some BOTS and
then if it's a double what do you do you
trade the kid across the street you're
describing how I buy weed in New York
City that's how you buy it
you just buy like what I hope it's good
no no come on I'll do this it's how I
Cali you no no but no no no listen bro I
don't like delivery service yeah cuz I
don't want to send you away
I think 95% embarrassment for me was
ever getting a hooker was that after all
[ __ ] at if that's not what I ordered
you're going without knows never what
you order no if you tell me you're
sending over [ __ ] Brigitte Bardot I'm
waiting for Brigitte Bardot she comes up
with a missing foot we're gonna have a
problem taking us down the [ __ ] yeah
well my move was I would jerk off before
they got there and then not answer the
phone
you're [ __ ] dirty best no yeah that's
why I don't like that [ __ ] I don't like
just calling some women unless I know
you go missing less I'm buying weed from
you from eight years and you actually
call me up and go like that you like the
Katt Williams Joe yeah no dawg and when
I gave you last week yeah this is
stronger then I'm one of those dudes
where I take your word for it but for me
just to call I like one of these
services around here maybe the best you
got they're gonna give me like 16% weed
and I'm gonna be stuck at home I don't
want no delivery none yeah we all it's
getting a little bit better in New York
City now if you have a hookup like but
it's nothing like it is out here
this shit's [ __ ] crazy this is Krait
now it's even they're getting you the
next step achievement crazy at home bro
now it's going to go recreational now
that we'd store opens at 6:00 do the
family anymore yeah of course
6:00 a.m. to 10:00 at night it's closed
for 8 hours 16 Howard day to weigh that
with shifts two girls work over in them
are you hooked up with a speed we've got
bus speed we'd saw through the [ __ ]
bass is the best unless they gave me a
thing a weed I don't even know what it
is I'm not [ __ ] with you there were
gold flakes in the we'd go flakes Joey
it's I I don't I mean I'm not making it
there's no way a little bit it's gold
inside of the [ __ ] weird I don't even
understand it you saw those mushrooms
yeah it tastes like life
no they taste me disgusting now see
horse [ __ ] out there was spotless Bobby
spotless mirror spotless and Lea almost
puked his [ __ ] heaven he didn't even
taste the taste it's like the texture
does it to me I don't know what and I
know what imported in between two stars
like a cheeseburger like a [ __ ] and
it falls out
yeah you just freaked out on the
freakout I figured out about everything
that's then he freaks out on the
freakout lily is one of the most fun
people to smoke weed with and he never
says no but whether Lee is smoking
eating or no matter what ways consuming
it it looks like it it is painting him
to put it in his body like another like
it is [ __ ] causing him so much pain
to get like he went to eat the animals
he like he like drinks water like it's
like really causing him like horrible
horrible pain and I feel bad for you I
have to do I had to learn how to do it
it's like the competitive eaters and
where are you self - just [ __ ] put in
your mouth and chew yeah but now when
you eat ten of them I like tonight we
didn't go that crazy but if there's some
nights like the last time you were here
where I had a 15 yeah it takes eight it
will take me an hour to eat 15 stars
she's normally takes you ten minutes if
I dip them in hummus no but that's why I
don't know if you guys ever get mad at
like wheat or wheat in movies whenever
they say they can't taste it in the
edible I just turn the
turn it off because I've never had that
what bothers you is like the taste it's
hard for you to get down is that why you
need to drink the water with it yeah I
just take a like a pill that's all just
the taste cuz I love the taste of it
like the taste
it feels like Andy to me I love come on
man even like I swear to [ __ ] god are
you kidding me you react the way I used
to react to whisky when I was like 17 or
18 the first time I take a shot of
whiskey where it would like you'd really
like god this is [ __ ] awful you know
um but the taste of marijuana whether
I'm smoking it or eating it I swear to
god I love it smoking is different than
eating though for me I like it I like it
when a good joint tastes good like that
like it like there's a that's something
I enjoy that ingesting marijuana I know
from who knows maybe it's from there my
early days of the the brownies where
they they just taste really like you're
eating dirt over the last six years I'm
viewing you every [ __ ] oh yeah I've
ever done you everything I'm giving you
an island gummies yeah I've given
gummies these has it all cookies [ __ ]
deal and drinks oh yeah drinks we would
weigh a hundred and sixty-five pounds
let me tell you some these fantasy is my
friend so that's okay to be dropped off
on a lounge room surrounded with your
five favorite food awesome mounts and
refund you don't have to wear clothes
you could eat naked cuz nobody ever
watch eat yeah you're alone you're alone
I love it love it about the sound great
lick the troll came on the podcast and
sausages and all this [ __ ] and marinara
sauce and a sausage and he brought two
loaves of bread I brought that loaf of
bread there was one point
they thought about we and he was over
the bow like at the end of the night he
was over it like getting he and he was
ripping the bread and dipping it and
there were crumbs everywhere all over
his face the table and loving him
leaving and I came back three days later
they get hired by myself one day and I
looked around here who was like a
[ __ ] bomb and at this place there was
bread everywhere when I think that was
bright on the floor the chairs wasn't
all me some of it was me but it was some
of it was me some of it was Nick I mean
we read here like [ __ ] animals we got
so [ __ ] high that's the thing I don't
like Anders did the [ __ ] we ate tonight
makes you [ __ ] on 3/11 45 yeah makes
you want to kill them on the [ __ ] I
asked my that's my dentist gotta be
prepared I have [ __ ] [ __ ] hunger
why it's Adam why tonight I can control
myself what an edible are you that that
will first then I need another half then
I'll either piece of salami the salami
still won the [ __ ] war yeah every
time I go to the store because you have
my apples for that reason and then then
all works until I'm high
I've never won like that's amazing to me
that you actually go for the Apple
although they taste so [ __ ] yummy
apples and peanut butter is one of the
best snacks and I can't have peanut
butter in the house wait peanut butter
you lose weight with all-natural peanut
butter peanut smashed up dog I didn't
eat the whole jar in one night I'm a
Geoff dude it doesn't matter it's just
[ __ ] forsake your [ __ ] natural i
watch Jeff when I went to prison
Geoff was there from college I can't
desert gym now because I won't go they
have organic Geoff and they have
all-natural Jeff who they yeah I do
so here's the deal listen okay I don't
like Apple I don't like being a mom I
used to weigh 330 pounds okay and it was
specifically because of weed okay my
first year of college I started smoking
weed when I was almost 18 years old
okay first time I ever smoked weed I was
almost out of high school I was I was
like a proud like straightedge like oh I
never smoked weed I was proud of the fat
and I didn't do drugs or drink or
anything right and me my friends just
like out of nowhere on a whim we're like
let's just [ __ ] get high one day and
we you know smoke the joint I never
turned back that was at one joint you
know when they say you don't get high
with your first joint yeah I didn't I
got [ __ ] dude I got so high there was
and then I've been chasing the dragon
ever since is that first high I rolled
around on the floor with my friends
laughing harder than I've ever laughed
in my entire life I saw System of a Down
in Incubus and a mr. bungle that night
hi for the first time I was fight was
incredible like I of course I became a
drug addict
what a [ __ ] it's like falling in love
it was unbelievable it was like an IU
when I was a kid I [ __ ] hated
everything that was associated with
marijuana yeah Louie don't look at me no
same thing won't care no earrings no
that dirty look people had with the
scraggly shirt no I didn't leave nothing
to do with it and I played basketball
with the karate and the people I went to
karate we were anti [ __ ] everything
that were even anti-sex those young
[ __ ] little
dummies but in North Bergen that was a
completely different game 11:00 buying
the first split in the first nickel bag
$2 a piece and smoking a joint Luis
Gomez I found love yeah iPhone Wow you
hear music music yes I had like maybe
eight out was the first time I got hot I
mean I knew music yeah but at that time
my personal collection had probably had
like seven hounds the beach boy son was
like corny return fire once I started
smoking weed I fell in love with every
aspect of music it seemed like well
isn't the music no matter what language
no matter what they say I always found
something good in it I mean don't get me
wrong
Yoko Ono sounds bad even if you [ __ ]
do heroin you know Yoko Ono's just bad
but everything pretty much sounds great
when you're smoking pot and you have
like earphones and you're relaxed and
you clear your mind
to sit back and just listen to music a
lot of people can't do that that's how
that was my escape
when I was yelling for my shoes a kid
yeah I would just get as [ __ ] up as I
could and just tuck myself in a corner
with your phones and just that would be
my world that would be my safe place you
know and it still is in many ways a lot
of times I'm having a [ __ ] up dad just
go home close the door in the office
plug the phone put it in the [ __ ]
desk and I put the earphones on blast
down you know sticks all songs from my
use something I haven't listened to and
I get my bearings back to me for a
second
that's why I like I like Pandora as if
as opposed to Spotify I just got just
downloaded Spotify because Pandora you
could like discover [ __ ] did you forgot
about I put a it's like a 90s rock
station on and like [ __ ] just comes up
that you wouldn't think about that
you're not gonna like happen upon you
know what I'm saying I got serious and
YouTube does the trick yeah that's it
that's great to youtube if you get
something on YouTube you like and you
listen to it two or three times again I
think it gets your whatever because all
this song from that era will pop up yeah
so from listen to a e i o you from 1982
disco all the other disco [ __ ] that was
on the station with that pops up on
YouTube so I'll get like you know all
that [ __ ] that's literally how they
[ __ ] make you an addict I do it I
love it that's why today you know you'll
come to me
this guy'll come to me this girl come to
me and I'm like mental notes I'll write
them down you know what when I got
insomnia when I wake up at 4:00 in the
morning and I can't sleep I'll listen to
that man you told me about
if you don't assign my little guys write
it down I'll take UCD from me at a
[ __ ] show I might always it took for
a year what I wasn't doing yeah
and when I listen to it that's not a
holy [ __ ] I wish I would listen to the
sooner I show threw this away when you
gave it did you play music cuz you're so
you're so passionate about the years I
was in the band like in the sixth grade
would you would you play I was a singer
with John bender this could break canal
this could be Norman but I always play
counter jokes because that was my mom's
bar I had a big association with a lot
of Latin musicians so I always played
college my uncle plays the Congress my
family has abandoned Cuba so I would
take two conga drums and put songs on
the jukebox at the bar and I put a hat
on the floor I just play Congress for
donations it should be [ __ ] there five
bucks
six bucks to stop what is done twenty
eight [ __ ] stop yeah I was there I
play drums I was in a rock band in high
school and you know probably the my
really my first year of college but uh I
was very passionate about music then I
lost the passion for it I loved as a
musician you wanted to be in a band I
was in a band I wanted to do that and I
had a passion for music at the time like
I loved I love going to see like live
shows a bands like it was such a big
[ __ ] deal to me and I don't know what
happened maybe once it was really when I
sort of comedy maybe I just became like
such a narcissist and like selling my
own thing
this really I remember there was a
moment where I saw there's a really
great cover band in New York they might
not even be around anymore but they used
to play on Canal Street in the canal
room and they used to do like crazy
[ __ ] 80s covers like really dope and
they had a really cool live show like
like lasers and like cool [ __ ] really
cool like New York experience you go see
this band and I remember my check my
son's mother were doing this like seven
years ago
I'm before my kid and we're watching
this band and I remember I'm watching
them play and I got bummed out watching
them play
because I wasn't performing I wasn't
doing what I was supposed to be doing at
the time and I remember it was kind of
moment over like [ __ ] dude I'm like not
enjoying this like a cool thing that I'm
not really enjoying as much as I should
you know there's two avenues for that
either you became a comic I think you're
beating yourself up with the dark
assistant [ __ ] and all those [ __ ] big
words I don't know what the [ __ ] you
saying but listen man it comes a time
where you have so much time do you
understand there's no way you have so
much time
you only have so much time you you you
only have so much time and you have to
start picking what's important do you
want to make a living do you want to go
watch bands play now you know if I lived
in New York right now I would have a
goal of two clubs a month but all that
[ __ ] has changed then when I lived in
the city well now that the city was all
day of type [ __ ] on name promoted on the
radio and first-come first-serve there
was no online you know yeah I get
tickets online that's all gone you know
right so for me I'd be like a dinosaur
myself unless you say to me Joey this is
a great band let me take you to go Sam
like I'm thinking I'm gonna see Joe
Perry tomorrow I don't know if it's sold
out enough see if it's sold out Lee
tomorrow night at somewhere in Hollywood
you know I'm technically going to see
Joe Paris I say we get some Joe Perry
tickets yeah one [ __ ] Luther
King there last time I seen Joe Perry
was in 83 at Radio City Music are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what
that's great thirty five [ __ ] years
I'm a [ __ ] during this song anyway no
you have so much time bro and people get
angry with you how much starting at 110
110 a ticket it's not written for
general admission Jesus where's the po
boy it's so that might be resale unfor
yeah where is it at the Roxy the Roxy
yeah so it's great to see Joe pray yeah
it's great
hundred bucks see Joe play at the Roxy
[ __ ] yeah yeah I'm gonna get a big
Aerosmith fan but I guess he drive
I always have a big fan of his you don't
know was with me even when I was a kid
with music I always like I never I never
really liked even were like Pro
Wrestling like Pro Wrestling music I
always like the alternative to what was
like popular like brought up for some
reason it never like got me like excited
to like the the beat of the band or the
[ __ ] whatever it was it was popular I
was I was like um so we're thinking like
it's like era so I never really got an
Aerosmith but I was like really in the
Motley Crue I was really into [ __ ]
like Skid Row yeah Zeppelin yeah but not
the same way I was into Motley Crue in
Skid Row now things I got I had a sister
who's two years older than me so when
you have a sibling you kind of just
whatever they [ __ ] like you like you
know you don't really have a choice so
my sister was growing up like you know
we were I grew I was born 82 so yeah
dude she was [ __ ] cool is she even
she wasn't cool she was just cool as
[ __ ] to me so all the bands she likes
she loved poison so I was like a [ __ ]
toilet a little gay kid like poison
ocean we're in a poison t-shirt no
little Puerto Rican kid and have a short
New York or a [ __ ] poison t-shirt in
1989 and that was my first two concerts
ever poison the private poison pizza
party we want to get some z100 my mom
wanted a gets and then we saw poison at
the Orange County Fairgrounds and I just
thought I loved it
no I loved the whole excitement thing I
just don't like getting ripped off when
I find that parking for the RAM of games
is $100 I almost lost my [ __ ] mind
that you have to [ __ ] buy the thing
before you go to the game a [ __ ]
parking space a hundred oh yeah and each
time and then welcome Rams not even that
takes my whole [ __ ] excitement away
from going to see football in that [ __ ]
I movie theaters we're having to paint a
park like I said before I don't mind
an event and paying I just don't want to
feel [ __ ] he has I'm like a regular
American consumer I don't mind paying
the overpriced ticket alright I don't
mind doing that and sitting somewhere
nice with my family or my friends but
when you bang us at $450 for Rams
parking twenty bucks is like a [ __ ] 12
block walk or some [ __ ] like that that
that kills me that just kills me Joe
Perry the more like a hundred and ten
dollars that's fair you know I'm saying
that that's fair
but again not [ __ ] really it's not
Aerosmith it's Joe [ __ ] Perry yeah
I'll give you the half a yard and the
whistle home and I'm saying but a
[ __ ] yardstick on a Monday night you
got some you know I don't mind lifting
the rock but these people want to [ __ ]
in the ass and that's what do they wanna
do to the whole consumer look at this
thing with a little kid with the lol
doll they start [ __ ] in the ass when
you for some what he said my daughter
with the yellow out door oh do they
sound like that when you were a kid I
but they had when I was growing up what
they had pokemon cards they had those
aren't expensive well that was a kid a
golf guy when I was growing up when I
was gonna take those Miami trips at golf
gas stations for 50 Cent's you gave them
[ __ ] 50 cents on corn look at my one
50 Cent's but never like a quarter of a
Sun whenever you fill your gas tank
whatever you got gas you got three
[ __ ] stickers and you put them in a
book when you fill the book you wanted a
[ __ ] award or something like that you
know I mean this tops cards was kind of
like a version you because you're trying
to get the car you know the but it
wasn't the same type of [ __ ] top
cards will give you a little [ __ ]
love every three packs yeah I would just
buy a box like when I was a kid I would
go working my mother's bar I would
swindle him out of the twenty one way
another and I just go buy a box of
baseball cards and [ __ ] Jesus and eat
all that [ __ ] gum and get jazzed up
yeah yeah I was just [ __ ] I'd have a
stack of that stick gum that's the real
[ __ ] job builder right there that's
why chicks in the seventies don't mind
sucking your pipe because they chew that
[ __ ] bubble gum
bazooka shell gonna yeah I'm not for
[ __ ] bazooka that are the one that
the one that came from the face metaphor
is a breakthrough the one that is like
yellow and blue no the one that came
with the baseball card was pink okay
yeah and sometimes if it was if the
cards were rotten you got the hard stick
and you broke that thing in half and it
broke another thing that's worse than
the ship in prison you'd sliced the roof
or your [ __ ] mouth dog how many times
I cut the [ __ ] roof to my mouth with
bubblegum sticks from baseball back yeah
but we were tough we didn't give a [ __ ]
nobody's sued Topps baseball that really
get put you in the gun you dumb
[ __ ] well now they're out of
business are they no they're not
actually there's still but I think
they're dumb and UFC cards and nothing
works the [ __ ] jaw like a piece of
bazooka when it's old like it's stiff
but you still take the chance to give it
a lot of saliva and you're trying to
break it down with the enzymes like this
is an analogy no no there's a little gum
yeah everyone so why you going to the
bodega and they're very fresh yeah you
have that yeah I say you have like eight
cents and you look around you don't want
to put eight cents in the [ __ ] pain
for somebody for some [ __ ] whatever
they come in would touch over his
fingers which of the bazookas [ __ ]
three cents a piece and you know his
eighth give me to you even leave two
cents you take two of them and before
you turn you open you look at the front
page of the daily news and as you open
up the gun you're popular in your mouth
and you start chewing if it's fresh you
read the article detailing who's the
front page you're like wait a second let
me get 10 more T's for the wall there's
nothing like fresh bazookas man walk by
you know become like buildings I'm gonna
[ __ ] pack Lee they only coming on a
vigil used to buy this takes ten at a
time no you can buy whatever you want
no is there a nickel that's a baseball
stick no I know I know he chose to a
George W has a [ __ ] tattoo
perverse that was a five cent [ __ ]
party dude
they had a tattoo that a joke they had a
little [ __ ] story thing like a comic
book and the gum for five seconds yeah
what get what name one thing today you
can get for five cents that gives you
all that nothing I can't even make a
joke about it there's nothing yeah I
don't think you're binding for
five cents now yeah so it's really few
give you a kid in allowance cuz I'm
thinking about giving my kid an
allowance and 35 appropriate amount deal
imma bring it here once a week for an
hour and get this to do your ad reads
maybe do the clean up a little bit I
don't make you paint something for the
wall right and then I'm gonna give it a
slash alone with slash ten bucks an hour
foul tempers just solid kids haven't got
a good better deal now that's all of it
so pretty decent job actually I'm gonna
give a ten I'm debating moving to LA and
being that guy for you I can say you're
gonna try paint things for you and clean
up once in a while
listen I got it one more thing an hour
and her mind is [ __ ] ten minutes
well it's like [ __ ] 1000 for her life
she's gonna come in here rub the chair
with Chunkin rub this you know help me
throw stuff away I gotta hide all the
[ __ ] paraphernalia I'm gonna tell us
the wrong way - gum - help me with the
albums and then my son saw blunt in my
ear the other day I rolled a blunt I was
leaving him with his babysitter and it
was in my ear and oh no no no dude he
was already in bed
dude he was already a bet I rolled a
blunt after he was in bed getting ready
to go you know and the room is pretty
[ __ ] dark like really dark actually
but his eyes had already adjusted to be
him in the room so I walk into the room
to go get something I had a blunt behind
my ear so I was gonna I was gonna leave
and he goes dad that what's in your ear
and I was like I like a pen and I
thought it was a pen and now he brings
up [ __ ] every single day like your
memory get a pen in your ear why'd you
have a pen in your ear sounds like fun
but it's kind of funny like I gotta put
putting you and your wife syrup I know
okay so he goes what was he talking
about Peggy and not in my ear I was
carrying books and the pen was gonna
fall in I put the pen in my hat I did
tell him at was a Christmas whatever
holiday was there were edibles and
people had them and he wanted candy
because he saw Keaney there were like
tootsie rolls basically and I told him
that
obviously can't have that I was like
this I told miss Oklahoma so you know we
I I think that why do we demonize we
didn't like edibles and also the ship
people are drinking wine and whiskey and
beer at a Christmas party or whatever so
I just kind of the easiest way for them
to understand it is that it would you
know it's an it's for adults and it
would intoxicating understands what
alcohol is I don't have to you know
explain what weed is just yet but I also
felt like [ __ ] it like I'm gonna like
tell him you know the truth that this is
you know something that adults are you
know doing and it's not for kids and it
get you know drunk like it would alcohol
you know is it crazy whatever look 12 or
yeah you know whatever works for you
you're the guy that's got a deal with it
later
yeah you know I'm not saying you like
I'm saying whatever you tell your child
somewhere along the line you know I know
I got to stop smoking in the back room
at the hounds well I mean eventually
she's gonna get up and see the internet
where you're smoking weed on YouTube I
do the same thing like she I think she
cooperated anything beef no I said no
Jesus fed but I was smoking on the
boggling like [ __ ] Johnny Masada yeah
I truly join the grass or my turn around
[ __ ] I think she said it to herself like
my daddy smoking oh I believe that's
what I saw
but I see a lot of things she might she
might have literally thought you were
smoking like but the cigarette no no we
get literally like smoke I don't know
they're five do they know what that's
definitely Jesus Christ do you think
you're [ __ ]
yeah well no but they're five how do
they know what smoke is I don't know I
don't think I know but I think she saw
me she didn't say none to mommy and
that's all that matters because when she
does say something mommy and mommy will
say something
becomes a problem I don't know how to
deal with it I just feel like he's gonna
grow up you know I'm very open about
smoking weed I do it I like on camera
and there's pictures and I've weed
sponsors and [ __ ] bongs this month of
the podcast and it's like you know I
almost feel like if I'm hiding it this
is what I hide drinking a beer for I
don't drink but if I was drinking a beer
I wouldn't hide it from him you know
saying so I don't smoke in front of him
but at the same time I almost feel like
I have to have an honest conversation
with him he's five years old now it's
like at one point do you know is he
gonna know that his dad you know yeah
burn that bridge when you get to it but
for right now in today's society you
can't be oh listen all you need is for
that poor kid it's 6:00 to go into
school and tell one of those peanut
allergy kids that his daddy smokes
marijuana and next thing I get enough
and you're doing your what gets a letter
in the mail
yeah so you don't need this [ __ ] right
now that's true you know this is but
that's what's [ __ ] up though because
you wouldn't get a letter in the [ __ ]
mail you wouldn't have anybody knock on
your door if you were drinking if you
were getting hammered every day that's
[ __ ] up it's the one language you want
to take it to the Supreme Court take it
but you know that's the way life now
we're gonna fight this on Martin Luther
King's birthday know why they do this in
Iowa I don't know I don't have the
[ __ ] answers all I know is I like get
high I get any of the mornings before I
see the devil whatever the [ __ ] but back
to you in your situation any of
anybody's situation as a parent my
stance is basically this okay if your
child sees you drinking or smoking pot
you're their hero
if they come today the opportunity to
come and three kids come up to your
child and say hey man do you want a
drink and you're like they say yeah why
wouldn't that you actually told your
[ __ ] kid that you they you actually
dropped them somewhere to spend the
night because you and your wife were
going to some party and the next day
when you pick the [ __ ] kid up you
can't stop talking about you got that
angle
kids remember what a [ __ ] his mom was
being at that party and not really but
remember that [ __ ] kids remember that
those little things and then when they
were they're 16 it's that time they get
asked do you want a drink
sure why wouldn't they they're [ __ ]
hero drinks right why wouldn't it
why would they would you be upset if
your kid at sixteen and started smoking
weed I don't know I don't know I'd have
to see what was the purpose who was she
smoking it with what is the situation
you know I don't know I think the scary
part is is like you're right the parents
are definitely heroes but especially now
with everyone on like all the TV shows
and and everything online they have ten
heroes fifteen heroes so now what it's
different doing you got a kid get on
[ __ ] [ __ ] away it was Superman when I
was a [ __ ] kid don't ya on please the
problem is that I just the kids that I
grew up with that their parents were
like drinkers and I see the kids that
their parents have didn't drink and now
I'm taking mental notes about my
situation number two my situation was
completely different
when I was fine with the PA out and they
take you over and show you about drugs
and what they didn't show me the [ __ ]
weed okay
my mother took it out and showed me at
the [ __ ] house and said you see this
[ __ ] you know do the actual drugs oh
yeah my mom had weeded the house coke
you know whole [ __ ] deal when I was
two my mom my mom made all our mistakes
with like letting on that she was in the
drugs with my sister and I was too young
so I didn't know until I could look
later on but uh that's crazy like I had
no idea what drugs were I had no idea
what anything was until I was way older
it's so weird that then you have kids
that their mothers own crack
or dope and the kids take care of them
and they live their life because they've
already seen the other side of a young
age so there's two sides for that coin
yeah I'm following me I'm not accusing
oh yeah yeah yeah I don't think there'll
be there's nuance with everybody and
everybody reacts to the world
differently and I'm just talking about
light everything you know the word party
and what all these things become in your
house when you're talking in front of
your child
you know you know I saw they affected me
I saw all those words all those green
lights effectively go so there's a
reason why some kids smoke when they're
12 and some kids likely smoke in college
yeah there's a reason for that bro and
you have to decide what you want Cory
ask you a question you all know those
guys that wants to smuggle your son when
he's 13 and running buddies I'm hoping
and you can the kids come over and they
listen to your stories about with Cheech
was done
tell us more mr. Delmas go [ __ ] yourself
nobody wants me that guy no no no Andy
be honest with you I want my son to
hopefully never want to alter his
reality yeah I'm hoping that he's in a
you know once you know he's just [ __ ]
you know the the the ideal you know
thing is you raise your kid in the world
where they just want to [ __ ] you know
they love every moment of life that
you've created for them but you know
that's just not at this I guess none of
the kids I mean look what my kid
probably smoke weed one day yeah you
probably yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm smoking
a joint that's why I saw it guys kind of
[ __ ] baked in here but yeah I'm dads
and that's like yeah I look dude I don't
know man that's kind of tough to deal
with thinking about that that's the
other thing is like the stupid [ __ ] we
say on podcasts and like the crazy [ __ ]
like you think that's part of like you
know doing this that where you go like
how I'm gonna have to explain to my son
one day some of the stupid [ __ ] I've
said and like hey it's a joke and he's
gonna understand the nuance of what that
joke is especially growing up in a world
where it's very much like geared toward
social justice and you know being a
liberal and you know he's going to a
private school and it's very much like
do these [ __ ] did they did an
interview with
mom they were like what are your
thoughts and social justice what are the
most important issues with you like the
it's nothing then as part of the
curriculum at this point and I want to
explain to my kid one day the [ __ ]
you know the words that I use and the
[ __ ] that I say and that's something
that I haven't even completely put
together how I'm gonna do yet you know
no you burn that bridge when you get to
it you're always thinking about you
always looking at them you loving them
and you're thinking when the day you
have to talk to him about this or that
you're hoping that day never comes me
he's still want to talk to me about it
now you want to see where they [ __ ]
stand you know you learn two things when
you grow up without a parent or with a
parent and you've learned so much as a
kid you watch your friends and you see
how their parents act and then your
neighborhood you look at your people
that you grew up with and you know the
type of parent you want to be you see
what the results were I'm 55 I grew up
with kids that are really [ __ ]
successful and I think about why and I
you know and it's very easy they came
from a strong [ __ ] houses and they do
drugs and they did everything yeah they
were right there snorting coke only what
their house and the bricks was so
[ __ ] solid that they never forgot who
the [ __ ] they were do you follow me and
then I got other guys that just went off
the [ __ ] deep end and never came back
or they're coming back now or they still
[ __ ] run in this game and I know what
they would treat him like it that you
know so I'd rather go with
with the what the [ __ ] is going on out
there all of a sudden was dying in here
smoke inhalation
I opened the [ __ ] door and also this
[ __ ] fast and furious meets [ __ ]
live PD out there so it's up to you I
mean that you're look at your child and
you know what you want for your [ __ ]
child what the [ __ ] do I wanna do I want
them in this mix do I need this [ __ ] you
know if you expose your child and play
it off like this is [ __ ] cool and this
is you know
listen it's still against the [ __ ]
law okay there's still places so it's up
to you it's at that time you gotta make
the call
yeah I gotta get out of there and stop
smoking around the back she's gonna be
seven when they sure when he looks at my
hands when I come back in the back oh
really
she senses something a [ __ ] stupid
yeah you don't think she [ __ ] the
smells in my office she don't look at my
drawers yeah there's no edibles in my
drawers I got shelves she can never
reach the edibles Hemans and whatever
else I put in the [ __ ] safe
nobody could find [ __ ] oh that's you
know so I don't want to bump into [ __ ]
until the drawer now there's no paper
pens in the drawer what she has access
to there's nothing in those drawers well
and you try your best brother that's all
you could do I mean you don't want your
kid doing drugs or being a [ __ ] up
early on you know I believe that every
kid's gonna do what think I'm gonna do I
was going to do I was destined to do
what I was gonna do I grew up on a bar I
saw the good and Bad's I grew up with
people store the coke I saw people shoot
happen when I was a kid I had a bunch
options
I took my chances as well knowing the
consequences and ended up in prison
don't get [ __ ] around you know do you
really learn I mean when the [ __ ] do you
learn so you have to live your life and
at one point you have to cut the
umbilical cord from your child but why
you have the umbilical cord you lay the
best bricks that you collect
that's the only way I could see it now
at my age what I've seen you know now I
agree I mean I I think it's uh
I think people don't put enough thought
into um kind of what that means you know
I think well you even you look alike
you look like kids menus at restaurants
dude it's the shittiest [ __ ] food in
the world like it's just like just at a
baseline why God give them [ __ ] you
know macaroni and cheese watch it you
know that you know they killed him I say
it's it's it's a very weird thing it's
the opposite it's like and you see like
when I went to my kids Orient or an
orientation for the parents at this
private school and dude it was like
college it reminded me of like when I
went to college my first year of college
and or my second year of college
to do this big orientation that welcome
they make this big [ __ ] deal and this
is kindergartners gone into and you know
I was like in my mind alone this is
actually the way it should be it should
be a much bigger deal to go into
kindergarten then we're kind of making
yeah and I think people we push them
into a system that you know sit at a
desk you know act this way react this
way that person's the boss if you don't
learn this way and you can't learn this
way then your you know your problem
child it's kind of [ __ ] up you know
and that's like yeah I don't know I mean
look the fact that we're even having a
conversation and you know we care enough
to [ __ ] talk about it and think about
it and do whatever we can do about it
means that we're doing way better than
my [ __ ] mom you know ever did or you
know I don't know your whole situation
but yeah it's [ __ ] I almost feel like
we should put you know my son's mother
outside God Buster because I don't know
man if I had a fight if I had a shittier
chick to have a child with you know I
might I had to do that next that was a
[ __ ] lunatic
I would had a kid with her oh my god I
think about this every day in my life
like if I woulda had a [ __ ] dude I
was Oh dog hitting it raw I was doing
whatever it was crazy and I think about
how much I would have because I'm I love
my son there's no way I could like
abandon my child but the reality is dude
I don't know this [ __ ] was so bad that
like I don't know how to deal with it
but my son's mother she's such a good
[ __ ] chick and she cares so much
about like what he eats and what he puts
in his body and like [ __ ] the type of
education he has she makes it kind of
easy on me you know I'm saying she makes
me very conscious about it but it's like
I didn't get any of that [ __ ] when I was
a [ __ ] kid dude when I was a kid they
[ __ ] dude they threw me into a
[ __ ] school and they were like I
figured the [ __ ] out my mom was so I
look at what it is to be a parent now
and what my mom [ __ ] did and it's
like goddamn it dude she was you
shouldn't do anything I don't think ever
ever remember once in my entire life
being read to I don't remember ever
being read do ever just crazy that's my
brother you just don't remember
brother I'm telling you I don't I
remember you loved Spanish not white she
I'm half Puerto Rican half Italian Irish
so my mom was Italian I feel like nah my
mom died when she was 22
how was your relationship not good how
old were you when she passed I was 22 oh
you would yes she was uh what was she
like 40-something and uh you know it was
your relationship alone
I'm not really good yeah
no not yeah I'm not great what you do
for a living she was a hairdresser but
she really well I mean she wasn't she
was like um she was on I don't want to
sound mean you know I'm saying cuz I
think I'm [ __ ] on the dead and I'm
[ __ ] on my mom but she just wasn't
[ __ ] very motivated what I find
important in a person you know I'm
saying and an equality person you know
and in terms of what they do
you know and how they hella conduct
themselves she didn't live her life that
way you know I'm saying so she you know
she collected welfare in Section eight
and you know she did drugs and she you
know she wasn't really motivated to you
know kind of like pull herself out of
that you know and I mean you're you know
people are different like they either
you know they they kind of emulate with
their parents or their they go the
opposite direction and I went very hard
the opposite direction very hard like my
mom was [ __ ] you know a brutally
abusive violent like [ __ ] the way
emotionally abusive like really really
[ __ ] up
how was hurry how old were you and they
split or were they together well my dad
my dad was murdered when I was four
years old he yeah he was stabbed to
death not yeah that's right yeah my dad
was murdered when I was a little kid
yeah so yeah I was [ __ ] tough dude
yeah well it wasn't it wasn't a great
life you know
and what part of New York was this this
was in our Paterson New Jersey you know
which is [ __ ] like ghetto let's go
yeah people know people don't you know
people don't know like Jersey Gibbs
Jersey doesn't sound ghetto people don't
get it you know no it's very you gonna
let me tell you something yeah it's
[ __ ] and I'm one of those type of
dudes that but those east oranges those
say it Camden you got that [ __ ]
around in this shop yeah oh yeah you
know ulicia know my dad was stabbed to
death in the streets of Paterson in
Jersey
Alison it's
it's a [ __ ] up situation out there I
used to go to Madison to eat and that's
where the docks are right for
Longshoremen's but my son says something
badass and I used to do but when I was a
[ __ ] kid that was his poetry can do
it they used to call him father yahwah
wait man that was my father right now by
the hour hua was the dude that
implicated my mother last time she got
benched I'll shed before she died he was
a boarder he can do rather boring
palaces and he called the bar phone
that's for Coke the bar phone was tapped
[ __ ] so they arrested him he ran
on my mother but they had the tape to
some [ __ ] and got thrown out something
happening not tomorrow but uh [ __ ]
bad-ass it's a scary place Patterson
East Side and high school yeah that
woman that my mom went to high school
for a guy like a few months and that was
where she went to the highest [ __ ]
school bro yeah II said that movie
palace in East Side Patterson Kennedy
yeah there was a couple Patterson
how many Kennedy schools do they have in
New Jersey they're ever you would also
my mom was a habitual liar so I bet that
was a lie that she would tell me she
knew Madonna she's a [ __ ] liar anyway
I swear to god she's no but she knew
Madonna how did you know she [ __ ] she
didn't go beyond that she was a shitty
storyteller too was speaking of [ __ ]
shitty story toes was my bad Tony
Bennett around here somewhere and I'm
gonna spark of another joint do let you
know I do brother do what you need to do
and we go oh yeah so gone [ __ ] deep
baby
deep Monday the 15th I feel the
mushrooms yeah I'm feeling
then we're gonna do it so we your and
lay a little come on guys never guessed
come on man I'll move it once ever come
on all right all right
rapper the star let's pick a vice B side
like gentlemen
[Music]
you
crazy here what's happening now you said
we're doing a little bit you're cutting
a little [ __ ] piece take a chance
[ __ ] dog
oh is that for me or for lay that's
fully Lilly Lilly let's see what happens
there
wait looks like an Ice Cream Sandwich
look at this little one for you oh
that's beautiful right there
ah like a nipple it's a beautiful
[ __ ] delicious link let's see if the
puzzle live like this luckily if the
bars alright yeah you know we get this
[ __ ] dummy I want to give a big
shout-out to one of my main men mr.
dicks I had over there running [ __ ] in
the South Florida I want to thank my
mascot Cunningham putting the party
together Johnny Utah max justice
Federico Diaz Rey viscous Tony hurl and
Josh Garcia and James Michael ray Roy
Riv see upon something like that I don't
[ __ ] know you know I love you I got
high I [ __ ] up my boy song out of West
New York New Jersey my boys and I was
gonna put him on tonight and I [ __ ]
wrote the [ __ ] thing I can't [ __ ] the
went through the paper so I'll put it on
[ __ ] Wednesday night for you savages
you know I love you [ __ ]
it's a little band out of [ __ ] West
New York a couple [ __ ] Ricans couple
Cubans they gonna [ __ ] Guatemalan on
the organ I don't [ __ ] know goli
let's do this this is for [ __ ] this
for all the money right Jimmy my legs
Anka
don't worry about Martin Luther King had
a dream less readily and it was a leave
don't even bite it just drop it and put
the water over lately Jesus Christ
Lee pretend there's an Advil ha ha I do
your mouth don't chew it put it in your
mouth and drink the water above you
that's what you need and then spit it
back in your hand you know when you get
locked up and they do a statistic thing
on you
called whatever the [ __ ] it's called
when you first get to prison they do the
they do the diagnostic swallow we go
like a soldier take a look at least
choke it and swallow it like a soldier
this is what I'm talking about see how
easy this more you do a diagnostic and
they break it down pretty much they ask
you questions about your family and how
call ism and drug use and I wonder what
the statistics are of children will come
from a home where you know broken home a
home on Oh a broken home no no no how
many believe they are in prison I mean
they're almost an almost immeasurable
amount that didn't have some sort of
issue at home I mean where it was just
straight up to loving parents that grew
up I mean I'm sure it's the exception
those exceptions that I'm sure to exist
but even those people I'd have to
[ __ ] look deep into what happened
there because I would assume they were
getting [ __ ] by their uncle or some
[ __ ] like that
you know but I mean look at that dude
every I mean you look at like violent
crime dude is always [ __ ] for the
father being out of the picture is a
very very big part of it I know they do
studies about like kids not being read
to they do studies about you know you
know kids [ __ ] being exposed to
violence being spanked being you know
even the threat of violence at a very
early age then going on to you know be
violent later on their life there's a
lot of different thing
and we only [ __ ] have this
information now well it's do we just
started having the Internet in 50 years
we're gonna figure all this [ __ ] out 100
days oh we know it all right let me let
me break it down for you
the first fistfight I saw that I didn't
know what was going on
was my stepfather he then shortly after
that I got hit in the head with a
lunchbox the central part and that was
traumatizing as [ __ ] but I was also
traumatized this [ __ ] you open up the
goddamn window
I was also traumatized at the age of
three but at that time my father it
always [ __ ] me out it comes back to
haunt even the feds I don't remember I'm
in like one or two things but my
stepfather Amy was violent be weapons
all over the [ __ ] house you know see
the drug use I know my mom was into [ __ ]
you know my stepfather and Dudek just
all these variables and I sit here
sometimes my goal why don't i boy and
the my not violent why don't I and why
am I not in love with weapons there's so
many questions I ask myself so much you
know like why don't I like alcohol what
is my deal that I don't like to taste
alcohol I get sick and that whole scene
just [ __ ] me with me from time to time
I went to a couple Christmas parties I
went to bars it was great well it's I
didn't want to sit there for four
[ __ ] at once you know but it just
wasn't for the [ __ ] I was like I have
but I asked myself on a daily why I
don't [ __ ] love weapons at this age
and buy a ton of weapons with what I was
exposed
beat'em saying as a kid yeah so I mean
you had your own [ __ ] you know you went
you went to jail for violent crime I
mean it was like you know you know it's
not like that didn't affect you you know
I think I don't know I'm no [ __ ]
expert but if you weren't raised in that
environment do you think you would have
went to jail for a violent crime later
on in life I don't think so I think that
that's very much affected who you were
and I think hi Nick I was always headed
for the kid I think so I think so I was
always headed for the Kayla I always had
that demeanor
I was always headed to can I think
well it would feature you said my mother
died that's why I went I can let's
pretend my mother was alive 1980 when it
came I with a stay at the house
one way that I got into cocaine it was
just in my future it was too much there
I see it on your face now it's amazing
you know it's amazing how we were the
prime target we were the first white
generation that cocaine came and swept
us off our feet and again I do a
personal what's that another survey our
census I do a census of my friends and I
do a census of the people grow up with
families and the people grew up with one
mother in the house and the people whose
father died and you know what yeah they
all did drugs for a time being but they
almost felt one point got it together
yeah a movie are you with me I am but I
think there's still the people that
don't get it together and I think a lot
of them I look I don't know you're I
guarantee their studies I
guaran-fucking-tee yeah but it's like I
don't know man it's like I felt bad did
I grow you know I live in Harlem now and
it's very gentrified at this point I
live in a pretty nice block in New York
City right now like if you go to Harlem
and people that don't live in New York I
think they hear Harlem and they go oh
[ __ ] you know but Harlem is very like
nice and it's very gentrified meaning
there's [ __ ] white people there now
if you see one out of every three people
are white you're living in a nice
neighborhood in New York City now that's
like the a good kind of measuring stick
right and yeah I think [ __ ] I forget the
point I was making [ __ ] love I'm so far
I mean we are just to play devil's
advocate and we're all doing drugs
there's no judgement here but isn't it
just like there's a way I was very lucky
for the most part I had a very good
childhood there's some meat there's some
issues like any family but uh I don't
know like just looking at the way
especially my mom she was very no
nonsense about any of that she was a kid
and she did probably smoked weed and me
I mean I don't know she'll say no
but like the like she would never bring
me to casino like one of those like
something like that so like do you guys
think that at a point there's no like
it's just what we want to do like our
own personal things there's a way we
have to raise the kids but everyone has
certain things that they deal with and
then they make their own choices you
know I'm gonna enroll my daughter in
sports you know that's a given you know
what she likes all that [ __ ] so it's
gonna be easy
you know I was shown a jiu-jitsu tonight
and she was doing it there was a picture
of me the teacher today pull up Alberto
cranes and she goes Danny that she was
Jitsu someone like oh you're gonna go
over there and she's like maybe you know
so she's gonna swim and she's gymnastic
she goes the [ __ ] ballet yeah she's
got a recital on Valentine's Day you
know the whole [ __ ] deal it's
literally your name and [ __ ]
everything it's not even a debate you're
not you know growing up and we I don't
know I don't know if I agree with you
that you would have went to prison no
matter what you were done cocaine yeah
no I knew it I knew it no i mother you
know we you grace you know look I think
it's [ __ ] we got bombarded I'm not
this is again I'm not playing it really
is I at or Louis I'm not playing the
victim it
yeah I'm telling you that think of being
16 to that in California today in
California think of being 16 you got a
little mustache you got a little cute
girlfriend that's a Julian right or
wrong you're banging wow I'm gonna stand
there for a minute you're banging weed
right you're smoking weed and let's say
you were selling weed on high school
you're the cool guy right now weed is
legal right now if you're 18 you're
living in [ __ ] heaven I know I
wouldn't be if I just turned 18 and
we've just went legal and the way I like
marijuana I would be in [ __ ] heaven
just I don't even know my [ __ ] point
is yes I do
the point is the way that we this 18
year olds and the 15 year olds and the
16 year olds again surrounded with
[ __ ] legal marijuana just the way my
generation got swarmed with cocaine it
hit hard problem
I still remember being at that age 16 17
and noticing that a lot of people
[ __ ] doing it at that high school a
lot of kids and when we were right there
right there you know you're from
Paterson you're 20 minutes from the
[ __ ] right Lincoln Tom I'm [ __ ]
seven minutes under Lincoln though you
know but I thought I was a junior in
high school I was already copping coke
in the city I had two spots so what's a
junior in high school
seventeen years old it was a way
different I see the people now even when
I was in high school I didn't really
know people doing coke no neither
we got bombarded in a way that you
wouldn't believe it you know and then
Ozzy Osbourne with the blizzard of Ozz
snowblind
and then Scarface came out in 1983 no I
mean I said that was the beginning of it
yet and that's literally all the tenants
of your personality what's that Scarface
Ozzy Osbourne you know it hit us so hard
the cocaine culture it's so hard and
then it just kept topping itself
freebase so people start a freebase and
then all sudden there was crack cocaine
then there was this and then people were
shooting it it came at you from so many
directions that so many of us got
gripped it was inedible and I had every
temple because there was so much if we
seen a girl from 100 dollars in front of
us a grand two people coming to the
house going hey man I don't Louis I
haven't seen you in a long time
I asked your person can you move coke
and you're like Joey does it he does it
I guess I'm gonna leave your kilo I come
back in like a month just give me what
you have and your life I'll be dead in
two days that's that's what it became
yeah by 1984 it was everywhere
everywhere you went to a club in the
city it was on tables people snorting it
was everywhere every chick wanted to do
it
everybody was sniffling everybody was
sniffle that time people were walking
around and you know acting very
menage-a-trois
there was a cool generation now that
said acid disappeared [ __ ] THC crystal
disappeared reefer disappeared and a
whole new generation came on [ __ ]
cocaine and quaaludes straight-up
gangsta straight-up I'm 17 years old and
there's a way to make money off these
Lou you got him for two knobs and you're
selling before you know I want 100
quaaludes or last year when I was a cien
junior in high school three hours three
hours by the time you got them on 38th
Street and you walked the 76th Street
and you made strategic stops they'd
begun that's how fast
yeah my culture my neighborhood got so
bombarded with cocaine because all the
Cubans were in Union City it was right
there you're the city becomes North
burden that's it it was right there
I still remember going to apartments on
22nd in New York Avenue and where people
were [ __ ] stashed at you didn't city
became a [ __ ] stash pad that's where
they were crossing over the tunnel put
it in Union City and shoot it out
eventually they moved it out to Jersey
City and you know places where you could
just mix the people who were doing it
with Spanish so you got a mix but that's
a very interesting area is a very
interesting generation it was a very
interesting couple of months I saw the
cocaine takeover
I saw it coming I was right there I
heard about it for years you heard about
mumblings that somebody's dad did it now
my mom did it I knew since I was a kid I
always knew that I never messed with it
it was a different world I made believe
she didn't do it in my little world I
made believe she didn't do it let it sit
my mom told me one time she did coke
when I was like eight I got really upset
yeah you got upset I saw your rings
around my mother's no she didn't tell me
she did it that night she told me she
had done it right no and I got really
upset and with the funny was she was
trying to like let me know she did but I
then at that III really resented her for
not telling me she did drugs like did
she was a heroin addict you know so and
I shouldn't have because of the way I
reacted I [ __ ] wasn't ready for it
and I get it too they didn't want to
[ __ ] I just disappoint your kid like
that you know we're talking about like
the breaking it to our kids about you
know smoking weed you know or you know
[ __ ] with like telling you it gives
you a heroin addict that's another
[ __ ] level you know I'm gonna have to
tell my daughter I went to prison I
smoked weed I was divorced she has a
half a sister you know I gotta lay all
this stuff done but if I was Lee right
now I'd be pulling my hairs out of man
that's why I Lee's bald I don't think
about it I deal with it when it pops up
and I make a [ __ ] decision
and if i sat mercy down right now at the
age of five and told her what i did she
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about
she can't even correlate my mother and
father that she doesn't have a
grandparents on the other side he saw
she there's so many things she can't but
he's starting on just this way I told
the other day cuz he knows his grab he
met his grandpa said and he you know he
died that's his his his mom's father and
all his other grandparents are dead so
he understands that his grandpa had
passed away and he understands that
that's dying but he doesn't really get
what that means he doesn't and you want
to keep medicine you don't want to
[ __ ] explain in every [ __ ] Disney
movie it opens up with the scene of the
the father getting murdered or the
mother was Bambi was a fought the mother
it was originally it was Bambi the mom
got murdered but then I turned into the
dad [ __ ] Lion King and uh good
dinosaur oh yeah miss Boyle earlier
interesting yeah super early in the
[ __ ] movie and then I gotta watch it
with my kid and not cry like a baby in
front of him i watch all those movies
and cry in front of she don't give a
[ __ ] he just looks at me and giggles and
says Oh daddy oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy
no no I mean Doug why don't I tell my
daughter I said here with you we got two
thousand hours of us talking about
finger-banging
and even chicks out with coke rocks I
need my daughter go on iTunes when she's
18 listen to this [ __ ] no yeah so what I
do do is I do run a journal from my
daughter
and this sometimes I write it twice a
month sometimes a it's just a page a
time no big [ __ ] a pace just a page
what I'm feeling what I'm seeing in her
what I want for her little things what
your days should be like don't be a
[ __ ] promiscuous dirty [ __ ] that's
like every other sentence that's how
that's how every other paragraphs
ass don't suck dick to you twenty nine I
think a little notes at the bottom of
each page like you know special separate
no you
the ingredients watching us like a sushi
restaurant and they have an asterisk if
he roll food it's on your own st. Paul
Yaffe I'm not I'm just writing to uh
because if something happens to me I
don't want to have any [ __ ]
misconceptions like I did ya know much
about my father this is a guy in Miami
telling me my father got shot four years
I read the autopsies I saw the newspaper
articles I heard the stories from my mom
I heard the stories from her friends he
died of a heart attack he was doing
heroin you know and there's always
something so I till this day I have two
options I could go to Cuba but how high
or about to go to Cuba and decompose his
body and see if he's got to hold his
head or [ __ ] is wrong with people so I
just let it go with your hands dope you
want me to [ __ ] go to a psychiatrist
and open up [ __ ] wounds
I don't have time to believe right now
I'm too old I got a short window never
[ __ ] real you know we [ __ ] I think
people my son's mother used to be
obsessed with me like go on a therapist
and I've been in therapy recently and
it's good it is but like we do when
you're doing podcasting and you know
you're you're writing jokes I think
writing jokes is the most [ __ ]
therapeutic thing in the world if you
talk about dark [ __ ] on stage you're
trying to find funny [ __ ] and like
really dark [ __ ] up [ __ ] that is your
that is the most therapeutic way to
explore something that's [ __ ] when I
talk about my I don't want to talk about
my mom's death yet I well though I got I
have to obviously I talk about my dad's
death but um yeah I mean I I think like
that's you know I don't think there's
sorry guys my mushrooms are starting to
really kick in so I apologize was the
plan they said it will drop knowledge on
this [ __ ] but no I feel like
that's like um your therapy other than
anything else you know what's
therapeutic when you look at your son
and you're raising them your way and you
think of little things how your mom
raised you
you ever take them to the park and
you're looking at them after to let you
get this memory of you and what you
would go through that hey yeah you get
that I get to how all that's all get
that all of its are it's not really if
you touch and relive your childhood
well that's the thing right now a child
five is the age right five is age
because that's when I start to really
remember having a memory like a real
memory this white leader saying like ah
five they don't get it no no they get it
dude think back to your first memories
dude you were five you were in
kindergarten you remember of
kindergarten you remember going to
[ __ ] get to go in every day you
remember thinking though I remember
thinking you know very cognitively very
like I remember looking at the world
like it was the world it wasn't like
Candyland and [ __ ] Muppets it was the
[ __ ] world you know and that was I
was kind of like made a weird thing I
was like when as soon as my kid was old
enough to have a memory I wanted to make
sure that I was like doing [ __ ] you know
I'm saying like I had at least some [ __ ]
going on it wasn't like it's a girl
being like poor and like without like
toys and like you know that's [ __ ]
like you know the worse I grew up okay I
she gave me a lot of love you know
that's one thing she gave me a lot of
love she taught me lessons she punched
me in the head a few times she was
brutally honest with me which I really
appreciated I appreciate today that's
probably the reason why I am Who I am
was people you know I tried to be
brutally honest the [ __ ] it you know
life is too short
she spoiled me and that's why I'm
telling you I was always destined for
Jam because she spoiled me my I was
ruined
I was ruined at the age of 15 I already
know I can make money slang I hit the
number the eight months before my mother
died I hit the number on my birthday but
I took half of it I gave our piece to my
mother a piece to the bookie I put a
piece of the bank how much did you win
five thousand bucks
oh nice and I took the money and I
thought that like we say hit the number
is that like pick for her daughter
with a book make it like the own killer
Bronx and you bet to remembers six oh
four or five hours gets you 2,500 bucks
okay so it's just like the state lottery
it's just [ __ ] just like a state
right hey you don't go into the Bronx I
think I think I want 25 one I gave the
bookie if I want a lot tip I gave them
why what why does he get a $500 tip you
always give the bookie at five around
whatever because you have mother tab
most of the year not only that that's
the way it isn't he had a number Jesus
got them all the stories I took that
money and in those days there was this
guy named Joe and I used to buy four
ounces of weed from him for a hundred
bucks and I would double my money class
up and once I started making money from
the weed at 15 I started getting
mescaline from this guy named Lefty and
I would get little hits on that's always
the guy named left this got masculine
how you see it a hundred hits for $85
per you suppose for $3 apiece
yeah and then lefty started flaking on
me
it's like took more action to East
Stroudsburg Pennsylvania there's a
college there Pennsylvania whatever and
I started cop in there that was the
heavy shipment that would they were
bringing me ups
black beauties [ __ ] diet pills you
could snort them and get all [ __ ] up
but their specialty was acid and stuff
and I made a lot of money doing that so
I had realized at 17 that you don't need
to work that's not a good thing to
realize at the age of 70 yeah okay so
I'm telling you from experience here I
wouldn't blow smoke up your ass
I always going to do time somewhere
along the line I am the cooler if you
know my personality I'm gonna push the
envelope boy get caught and then I'll
figure it out I'll push the envelope
that's what comedians do we push the mo
then we figure it the [ __ ] out movement
so it was the what I was doing that so I
was always destined for it I'm very
lucky
instead of getting 28 years thought I
got four do you follow me it was always
gonna be a crapshoot all right Joey here
we go here's the dice go it could have
been twelve or it could have been two
years hit me before I took him like a
man and paid for my sins and I started
all over again don't get me wrong I
slipped a few times after that you know
but I thought I got my [ __ ] together
when I stole the Christmas tree I paid
the money for it a year later
I always tried to cover my [ __ ] bats
after that man and it's been and the
calmly saved me
the calmly saved that criminal and then
took the criminal medallion put it into
my family and parcel and that's what
same thing it's the same [ __ ] you you
know you we talked about sales before on
the show but it's it's all it's all it
all comes down to that formula and you
could figure out how to make that work
for you know for whatever you decide to
do it just happens to work really really
well for comedy you know
that's yeah I think that uh comedy idea
yeah comedy come as a cop here we go so
Italy eat those mushrooms the cops are
coming eat those mushrooms like yeah you
like the only alignment I'll test
positive for [ __ ] dude I moved to I
moved to New York from the suburbs when
I was like 19 and I started promoting
for a comedy club and I started making
like $500 a week selling comic up
tickets on the street and that's
literally what saved my life because I
was just doing whatever I could do $5.00
a week when I was 18 years old was like
a [ __ ] like a 1919 it was like a
million dollars my mom never made more
than 200 hours a week and why there's a
million dollars in here right that was
[ __ ] crazy did you walk around your
tip in Chinese waiters oh yeah I thought
I was gonna [ __ ] jack did I was crushing
it okay and I [ __ ] and yeah and I was
willing to do whatever at that point I
had no like moral compass so I would
steal I would [ __ ] cheat I would do I
would do whatever was did I
now I got caught up with some [ __ ] and I
almost it just happened to be that I
answered an ad to start selling comedy
club tickets and it made me five hours a
week it was just it was actually easier
to make that $5 a week selling comedy
club tickets then it was to go and do
the [ __ ] I was doing to me I was
making a lot I wasn't hustling at a high
level you know I'm saying I was hustling
like got a fob was like stealing
sneakers from motels and I got a friend
of the thing that took the things the
the tags off so we'd steal like four or
five pair of sneakers and sell them at
the pizzeria I mean what's a unity it's
like stupid [ __ ] this is like the worst
garbling ugliest bread of course got
weed how he is writing gas money is my
thing what do you mean you with a Nick
the Greek what do you mean
Nick the Greek way with you get with the
jewelry yeah well it's a real nerds are
shady people if you ever meet a person
who owns a pizzeria I promise you that's
not the only thing they do they have
some other [ __ ] crazy cover I have no
idea okay
look into their eyes little new pizzeria
owners eyes they got [ __ ] darkness
behind a nice Nikki pizza Nikki [ __ ]
pizza i tortured that guy Nikki pizza
tough but I was loyal I was a loyal
soldier yeah nice tucking out with Nikki
pizza but we caused havoc in that done I
got I got a run to get pissed guys I'm
sorry I'm gonna forget being in there
one night two dudes got into a fight and
one two that's what he used to put the
full container with mozzarella cheese
the sugar ones filled and they start
like going like this no one guy Friday
took the fresh pepper and threw it at
him this guy took the parmesan through
him and also it was a cheese fight and
there were Parmesan cheese the place was
covered get up let's do it go Pete oh
yeah now I hear this now this no no I
really want to hear this now that's it
but they just had a [ __ ] mouth brawl
I thought the owner of the pizzeria was
gonna come out with a gun and shoot
people in the head only the dark [ __ ]
PETA he Nicky pizza was a degenerate
gambler yeah which meant that if you a
hungry one then you went to a tree and
there was a sign be back at 4:30
he was
the Meadowlands and there's a good
chance he might not come back no he
always came back he always came back bro
that was Nikki he came back in time for
dinner
he was a Greek he always came back how
pissed were you there when he wasn't
there at three cuz that's like right
after school he must have been stolen
let me tell you something when you went
there at 3 o'clock and Nicky pizza was
close bro you drew a forfeit because you
were stoned and you would count on that
ham cheese and he was gonna put on the
tap he had an attack you don't have a
tab in high school yes we did I had a
tab at Nick's Pizza Jesus - ways the
Chinese store the Chinese store by 38th
Street the dragon grocery I had a tab in
there for a while ok
I had a tab at this prick store ok 38th
Street and [ __ ] Liberty Avenue yes I
did yes I did
you ran tabs and you pay them on Friday
you didn't need [ __ ] to have money on
your long times if you play basketball I
didn't have I also had a tab at the
[ __ ] place around the corner from the
basketball court when I was a kid they
sold iced tea and lemonade and orange
juices and those you know like regular
milk containers oh god yeah only the
16-ounce ones remember those no no ice
tea's first came out oh the big ones
they came out in the 16-ounce lefties
way before less tea ok this was like a
[ __ ] mom-and-pop dairy when they
would make this lemon iced tea that was
delicious it hit the spot and they also
made fruit punch or something and we
would go around the corner from 38
basket
dirty a street basketball courts you
walked up about 50 yards and right
before you hit that body shop there
there was a [ __ ] uh a little joint
there that soldiers today you know they
they sold them to truck companies to
come pick up the juices it was like okay
right
so how much of a tab did you have going
every week do you have like a hundred
bucks everything yeah
no the dragon the dragon dragon the the
Chinese place
all right listen
the Chinese place I would only front
from on Sundays when my mother was alive
once my mother died never front of them
again my mother would stop and then pay
the tab on the way up the hill to the
bar and then the [ __ ] door I had one
side yeah because he used to make steak
sandwiches on Friday so it's basically
for Friday's and then there had the hash
ways my tab was dead till 1983 and then
I had another tab in 94 you could run
your tab up to about 50 bucks and turkey
sandwiches potato salad I would pick up
the [ __ ] on at the local like deli on my
mom's tab for her I pick up cigarettes I
was allowed to pick up cigarettes with
my mom with a note not even a note not
even though it wasn't note there was a
note I didn't know you have a note from
your mother that will give you
cigarettes Lee that's crazy
that was a dollar 75 a pack now our
favorite 7-eleven got busted did they
yeah right is it 18 or 21 Califano well
I know that we go to a [ __ ] spot I've
been going to that 7-eleven for years me
and Lee I've been busted cuz it's close
to the police station so nothing's gonna
go down in there nothing never goes down
in there it's close to a police station
like 50 yards I don't [ __ ] with this one
this one down on the corner I'm like no
Lee that's a [ __ ] somebody's gonna
get shot in there but that one over
there is a cool spot and it's cold and
it's close to the place we hang out at
the fourth wall in fact he gotta meet
some girl - more like dentally
at seven o'clock I'll be there at six
seven eight she's a Chinese girl or a
asian girl I just talked to it tonight
the size 11 he's gonna meet you this so
how long you in town for me I just till
- till Tuesday then we're gonna be doing
what are you doing yeah I just said I'm
gonna kill Tony tomorrow but I can't you
know I want a podcast network and I do a
podcast with Michael Bisping and we're
setting up a video version his show so
he came out to set up some tech
and then we also just signed Lisa an on
to the network who is um she's uh I
think she's I don't know they I don't
want to [ __ ] up the title but she's the
most famous like you know adult
entertainer no uh but like milf
entertainer okay oh she she's nailing
Palin that was like her her biggest egg
roll she played Sarah Palin but she's
[ __ ] really a great broadcaster she's
been on Sirius XM for years you know
doing um like a fantasy sports radio
show so yeah we're setting up her with a
couple things tomorrow so just a little
family podcast that you personally got
alright
technically I want for and leisure this
games is you're late yeah I got Legion
skanks which is like we just it's just
it's filthy we just we sure we talk
about whatever is going on in the world
that week and we really just try to be
as offensive as possible with it which I
think it's really [ __ ] healthy I
think we I think you need it I really
thank you you gotta get it out there
people are [ __ ] yeah yeah and then I
got another one called relapse podcast
which is kind of you know me just taking
a little bit more of a serious ticket
stuff and then believe you meet with
Michael Bisping and then I also host the
roast masters which is the East Coast
version of roast battle so Brian Moses
and Jeff Ross they technically produce
the show at the stand that I hosted
every week but we have a podcast version
of the show so they'll get that goes out
as well and they're all available on my
podcast network and you going on the
road oh yeah yeah I'll move to New York
which you know you would know man yeah
it's all things that she moved out doing
long distance for like six months
and then yeah good for you man you got
[ __ ] going on always hustling yeah I'm
excited I always read your tweets is
[ __ ] yeah I'm really I'm really pumped
it up now and then we might get you on
the [ __ ] legion of skanks podcast
next month don't when you come here that
way I think I'm home so just keep keep
keep on me check the website yeah jump
out on the website I'll let you know
what's great about [ __ ] really really
good time together
no I know we dude that mushroom is my
sibling oh yeah my son hit me I got the
32 minute mark you almost got me to cry
there was a little like I felt in my eye
and I was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I stopped myself yeah good but I
didn't get about mushrooms to do that if
you just mentioned my mom sorry about
that
no it's okay I have a mom that passed
also so I know yeah I'm from yeah and
you know when you don't have a mom you
grow up a certain way he grew up top the
dollar my mom a while about my mom's
good friend Madonna
yeah good friend Madonna that's [ __ ]
crazy and your dad died he got stabbed
in Patterson yeah yeah you know a little
bit on the kick side good for you man
you pulled out of that now you're not
crying the blues you're 35 now right
yeah you're a good man if you were gonna
be hung on heroine you would have been
stuck on heroin already
that's it better and you're [ __ ]
doing this awesome I haven't tried it
yet good don't try it I'm when I gave
some to Lee one night he thought it was
[ __ ] now you didn't yes I did hey
brother his uh I thought it was
available I gave him a little heroin
paddling heroin dust like a mushroom
Stein you should have seen him he was
[ __ ] he was drooling so this day
there's a bully I didn't even have
tonight him yes it was a little cookie I
mean I gotta test positive now but I
would love to take a full drug to
justice out of your system how long does
how in like a week wait you mean the
only way they do is pull my husband was
bid just to see what's in this [ __ ] B
it'll take a long hair like his pubic
hair do you know the all the amount of
time it takes for drugs in your system
that was in my house you hear rumors and
rumblings brief or cocaine 3048 see the
coke is three days that's quick get it
out
no but cocaine is enough those
metabolites cooking your [ __ ] body
yeah so let's pretend you get high on
one day I'm Friday night we're gonna do
two bumps no no you're gonna go deep in
on Monday night no Friday night come
[ __ ] animal let's say let's say you
get the party stuff on Friday night yeah
just getting you got on Saturday morning
you're gonna test positive till Tuesday
yeah Tuesday at some part of day you'll
be fine on Wednesday if you drink water
go for a little run lift some weights in
vain now help a little bit help
everything helps you know I'm saying
SWAT you if you sweat if you have a
little THC I know for a fact I know that
my last tent at the halfway house I had
a joint in my gym I had a gym I paid $35
for and downtown Boulder at the time I
had a punching bag
weights a bench and a cassette deck and
three cassettes like that said I had
like YouTube pyromania and Cathy Dennis
and I would go in there at night take
two hits up the joint it was a thin
joint I go can I put the joint out and I
get [ __ ] bait and I hit the bag I
drink water and I pee and I keep doing
that and I get peed once a week and I
never came back
really and they always test you for THC
yeah I'm one hit a weed supposed to be
one hit a week from one oh we can't be a
fat [ __ ] like I am then I don't think it
would work now this is me I think you're
fat holds on to this is not money Sarah
I read that one time something yeah
there's when I was 27 28 I was doing the
halfway house 90-89 yeah so what was
going on was I forced myself to always
drink cranberry juice
no soda and tons of water I would sit
there at night with glass upon glass
award especially if I did blow and
nothing really worked but I mean time is
the healer of all I know now they have
[ __ ] online they have should've had
shops that you're clean within minutes
really I do not know about that show
yeah
yes get a sound clean within minutes if
you know anything that cleans you you
and please tweet it to [ __ ] Louis
gomez over here I don't need to clean
your no no no no but find out what it is
that's interesting so if somebody ever
goes on your podcast cuz I like to find
that yeah I like to find out what the
[ __ ] it is I would love to know what it
is it's cleaner you are in a minute to
where you can go and just you drink it
or eat it
I went home I had a friend that was on
probation and he said he had got hit on
a Saturday to go pee on a Monday and he
drank one of those and then he had
little in his glove compartment and I
know what is that doing he goes to mask
it I'm coming back clean then he came
back clean my buddy when I was younger
would take it because he had probation
here we could they would check and he
knew when they were testing him he knew
exactly every time and the way it worked
he had to buy like [ __ ] three of them
and it was like a bright red liquid he
had a violent like vitamin shoppe he had
a yet a I this rules about peeing you
couldn't you had to pee a bunch before
this was jetted you had a pee a bunch
before oh hey it would be like pee and I
can't tell the story
you got to pee like three or four times
before you even took this the morning of
right then you had a chug like [ __ ]
the entire thing I was like a sugary
crazy thing and then your next pee had
to be that pee and when you peed it was
like a [ __ ] bright like orange color
and people we're getting popped all the
time for it but I don't know if it like
cleans your [ __ ] maybe maybe that's the
same thing that's scary I can't imagine
I know he didn't have fun I know I
didn't but if you just left
yeah if you just like we did the show
together now Julian Lewis yeah yeah I
can't imagine see that that's what what
I don't understand judgmental and yeah
it is I guess kind of but it's just like
wait with your on probation and you know
what's gonna happen like why put
yourself through that
why wouldn't you just cyber buddies
embrace you now just are the weeds I
guess you're addicted to something
really terrible no look here's the truth
you know it's probably good to stop
smoking we get every once in a while
yeah I did I did like a weekend it was
great
you got a four week oh hey they're like
six days once when Joey was there for a
while
it's not even impressive it's not
unremarkable you cannot deceive even
bring that into the conversation
no yeah and you didn't smoke weed at all
before you start Joey I mean I had
smoked occasionally No
nothing like a full term but you want
with the [ __ ] you are today she's not
[ __ ] pure piece of human and I've
lost it that was sick for a while said
and then smoking a bong hit so used to
be not terrible at it now I'm terrible
again
yeah it's interesting just this
interesting what we talked about unhappy
you [ __ ] came on the podcast we have
talked about it then crazy we talked
about raising our kids and what our
parameters were now which us I I just
saw the effect that had on me and when I
came time to making the decision that
was the deal closer that my mom does it
I'll be okay no that was the decision
all the way through do you think more
kids would die with hell it seems so
easy to kill a child you think about
this right like my kid you know he's a
[ __ ] pretty smart kid
and I think about like how close his
head has come to hitting like the
corners of tables and like cracking his
head down [ __ ] like whatever it is it
just everyday life
he's almost when he was a baby he was
almost dying [ __ ] maybe asked me to
be in a paranoid father but it just felt
like he was inches from death at every
single moment I'm surprised more kids on
thighs what I'm saying I don't watch on
the die bro no I of course who wants
children a guy even put that out there
they leave a message you want the
[ __ ] my little anybody and there was
always one you know you never want to
bury a child bro you want them to bury
you when you're old and [ __ ] second
really punch the [ __ ] ticket what's
your next date talk to me it doesn't
March 23rd 24th Boston Knicks comedy
stop oh [ __ ] week after be in Los
Angeles with the Legion of skanks so
yeah come out support gomez comedy calm
gas digital network calm is the the
website even there's 17 podcasts on the
network now so yes Oh check this out
you're [ __ ] regular Dick Clark
[ __ ] I love it
don't forget you Savage is Austin it
sold out so I'll see you next week in
Charlotte North Carolina
at the [ __ ] comedy zone alright
and that's it that's all I got right now
I got a date in Denver I'm waiting here
in the [ __ ] surgery so I'll keep you
detailed on that and I said I want to
thank my main man mr. Gomez for stopping
it's a short trip he could have been
doing a thousand things and study came
in here and [ __ ] drop some knowledge
on the mead some mushrooms like a man I
started to hit late I'll start there's
another episode of Lee in outer space
not quite where's the horn we um play
the horn then like the horn the the
siren is [ __ ] oh yeah hit me with the
siren is will you'll be feeling like
I've been violently by yourself
oh we're young we yeah people shoot
themselves that is tremendous I love
this [ __ ] horn all right
you breathe does your business have any
New Year's resolutions here's an
important one every business should
consider make your hiring process more
efficient and effective this year let's
zip recruiter help no one has done a
better job of transforming how you find
your business and the right talent then
they have all right and neither of a
great talent for your business this is
it zip recruit approach your job to over
100 of the web's leading job boards with
just one click
then zip recruiter actively looks for
the most qualified candidates and invite
them to apply they even review every
application to identify the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match okay that's why the zip recruit is
different unlike other hiring sites the
zip recruiter doesn't depend on the
right candidates finding you it finds
them no wonder 80% of employers who post
on zip recruiter get quality candidates
through the site in just one day
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire
find out why zipper kuna has been used
by businesses of all sizes and
industries to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
and right now tonight
our listeners our family can post jobs
on zip recruiter for free free free free
that's right free go to zip recruit calm
/ church CH you are CH that zipper cool
calm / Church all right listen
zip recruiter post your job to 100 of
the web's leading job boards with just
one click one more time this is for free
go to zip recruiter calm slash Church
number two I gotta thank my family over
there now that I'm gonna see this
weekend while I'm in Austin as far as
supplements are concerned they are the
[ __ ] cream they like crop from alpha
brain to new mood to shroom tech immune
you every [ __ ] to shroom tech immunes
I'll pop before we get on that [ __ ]
plane
I'll be sitting next to three little
Japanese guys with masks and I'll be
blowing I don't know [ __ ] time tip
top Magoo because I took my [ __ ] on
it some taking his room Tech immune here
I'm forgetting my words I'm sorry you
know how it goes at the end of the pipe
guess what he won anyway listen don't
take it from me gonna calm right now and
look at the great selection of
supplements without forebrain new new
mood shroom tech sports shroom tech
immune listen you can't go wrong you
want to go an extra round the jiu-jitsu
look at the shroom Tech sport let your
lungs expand when you eat those [ __ ]
mushroom to death all breeze gotten
those delicious containers you
understand me you'll be jumping up and
down for days but listen don't take it
from me go longer calm right now
impressive
Church man you get 10% off your first
order delivered right to the crib
who's better than you I want to thank
the zip recruiter one more time I want
to thank on it one more time I want to
thank my man Luis Lopez / Gomez I'm
sorry I always [ __ ] up people's lives a
good man in blue
gomez I want to thank him again I want
to thank the [ __ ] and I'm going
to thank you the church family for
fluffy and support don't forget the 25th
of January Charlotte the comedies don't
[ __ ] let's do it it's gonna be cold
but listen to the meals on its way I got
the meal just in case he breaks down I
gave the [ __ ] kind of the meal
rollerskates
the weight of the stars we'll get this
Charlotte see you Wednesday night I love
your [ __ ] stay black have a
great day
happy Martin Luther King Day black
people rise [ __ ]